you
make I tast Sweet Victory I know this
life me for me why would you bet on
Goliath when we got
bet vales contag this world are
entrepreneurs we no value to
haters inappropriate
stop very rarely very rarely do we allow
two Canadians on the podcast we don't do
that because it's in our code for pbd
podcast but we're doing this for the
first time I think it's the first time
Tom being a Canadian if you didn't know
if you're disappointed we have another
we have a we have a Chris pavloski
founder of Rumble Big Shot announcement
today I mean a massive massive
announcement today that they made uh
they just signed uh Dave poro and bar
stool Sports is officially what Rumble
wow and it's such a big deal I mean
obviously if you look at the market the
stock is up 30 32% just today after the
announcement being made that they now
would Rumble it's it was it's such a big
deal that The Dana White is retweeting
this and sharing it with the marketplace
on what's going on exciting news he'll
give us more the details there's some uh
you know structure of it that people
don't know which you will learn about
the public doesn't know what the
structure is I think he's going to
whisper to us a little bit and then at
the same time truth social today is up
75 78% today and a lot of people are
saying why is this happening it's
because they're thinking he's going to
be the candidate so truth is going to go
and he's not tweeting so everybody's got
to go on truth to see what he has to say
wow and that's that's a power play he's
making but before we get into the story
let me share with you what other stories
we're going to be talking about as well
one Bernie Sanders's wife signed a deal
publishing a book in 2017 she got
$16,000 check are you serious you know
today Publishers still waiting for a
book there is no book no when have you
ever heard a book taken this long to
write well see maybe maybe it's such a
powerful novel exercise of a Bible that
she's doing a lot of due diligence we'll
talk about that she hasn't been feeling
well yes she hasn't been feeling well
the Santos drops
out the Santos drops out a presidential
race and he seems so relieved it's am
that's the happiest I said yeah and by
the way I mean good for him it's
exciting to see him being happy in in 10
months and then NATO warns an allout war
in Russia next 20 years wait till we
play this one video for you and you'll
see what's going on with that uh doj
Biden's doj finally admits Hunter
Biden's laptop is real Tom has a
perspective that I think is very very
interesting that it point out on in
regards to pardoning that there's an
element of resigning and you just have
to hear this perspective he's got very
very interesting VI for VP race this
last Sunday uh right after the santis
suspended his race and endorsed Trump I
was on a Twitter x with u uh Mario NE
fall and it was a very interesting
conversation everybody wanted to know
about VP Tulsi gaber's name came up
again VI's name came up again and all of
it led to an interesting name of a
person that a lot of people are
wondering you know how this name was
announced we'll break it down for you on
a VP candidate that maybe nobody is
talking about stay tuned for that we'll
get to that here in a minute as well
Jordan Peterson fires back after court
dismisses his appeal of mandated social
media training the war has barely
started says Jordan Peterson the monster
Ohio lawmakers propos paying students to
attend school and graduate let let me
read this one more time so you know it's
not a mistake listen Ohio lawmakers
propose paying students to attend school
and graduate think about it we're paying
you to go to high school just please
stay in school we pay you to stay in
school instead of going out there and
causing
Mayhem and then Elon Musk will Elon
musk's politics impact Tesla sales fors
thinks it will buying out pay leaders
destroy destroying a lot of people big
developer launches a billion dollar fund
to buy distressed New York City offices
NFL announces pregame will include black
national anthem and on top of that NFL
is talking about how a pay-per-view
Super Bowl it may happen sooner than you
think can you imagine we're paying to
watch Super Bowl and last but not least
for some of you guys if if you're having
a rough day and and maybe you have some
sympathy left in you to give to somebody
else Nikki Haley KMI was a victim of
racism he's every day for for being
Brown she's brown yeah I mean she was
teased and you have to respect you're
Brown I'm Brown yeah but listen life is
hard and you know if you want some
uplifting uh news trans golfer Haley
Davidson wins women's tournament let's
go bro serious increasing chances to
help LPGA Let's Go baby go qualifier
obviously big news I'm sure many people
listening to this are celebrating but
with all of that stuff being said um
Rumble let's get back to this and and
you know with Rumble I'll give a man
update here here as well in a minute
just hang tight but with Rumble if you
look at the screen right there bar stool
joins Rumble wow the market lost their
minds let me get this straight Dave
portnoi the the the marketer that he is
right the
mouthpiece he's everywhere right
mainstream guy is officially joining
Rumble everyone's asking what's the
structure look like what does this
really mean the stock is up 32% there is
no better person to talk about the
structure and the deal then the founder
of Rumble Chris so Chris tell us about
what's going on here with the big news
today Patrick thanks for having me on
thanks for having me on guys um really
really proud to be on here today so yeah
earlier this morning um you guys broke
uh and we broke that uh bar stool is
joining Rumble um it's going to be a
deal that encompasses Cloud uh an
advertising partnership where our sales
teams can help each other um sell ads on
uh on Rumble
uh and uh bringing all their content to
rumble uh in addition to that uh they'll
also be promoting Rumble um on all their
social media accounts um only Rumble uh
so we're really excited about that
that's a that's a a big big thing for us
to have a a brand like bar stool really
kind of getting behind it but here's the
big thing and like the thing that I
think actually probably nobody knows is
and my favorite thing I think it's the
best thing the biggest thing is he
didn't come for the bag he came for
which normally most people do by the way
exactly yeah he came for the equity so
Dave pornoy is now an owner of rum part
owns part of Rumble we the deal was
structured with Equity not with with
with mostly Equity with a little bit of
cash so it wasn't entirely a a bag like
everyone else out there looks for so for
me that's super exciting
because you know he believes in this he
believes in this company he believes in
Rumble he believes in the idea of
creating competition in the market and
we need someone like Dave to get behind
something Rumble like him to get behind
Rumble I think that's like key for us
and having bar stool and all their their
litting like their massive list of
podcasts let me tell you all joining I
when I was looking at it I was like oh
wow you that one too like how many is it
Chris not to cut you I it's more than 75
I think I think it's like it's just like
a a massive list of uh of content they
have so bringing that on to Rum is like
huge because like all our consumption is
driven by content and having content now
in the sports category that they cover
you know very very thoroughly is is also
really complimentary to us because I've
been pushing sports like more than
anything since we went public we raised
roughly 400 million back in September I
can't I'm getting losing my ear it's
going so fast but like September
2022 and the majority of that you know a
lot of that money has been going into
investing in to content and in
particular the biggest Investments have
been going into like sports we invested
in power slap we invested in Street
League Skateboarding we invested in uh
Nitro rally cross racing um and uh we
even have the UFC on and we we run UFC
pay-per-view in uh in Canada so a lot of
the investment has gone towards Sports
and uh I think this is like a super
compliment thing to have is having bar
stool and all their podcasts on there
really kind of broadening that portfolio
Sports Tom let me ask you a question if
if if you if you look at it from an
Investor's lens when you hear and by the
way this is breaking news just not the
fact that barol joins Rumble is breaking
news we broke that this morning at 8
a.m. what's breaking news is the fact
that this is an equity deal bigger
portion of it based on what you're
saying it's Equity then it is Cash they
got some cash but mostly Equity how do
you look at it from Dave port noise POV
when he says no I want Equity cuz I'm
long on this company how do you process
that I process it a couple ways so first
let me put on my like Dave pornoy hat
it's like wow here's a platform that's
established it has a public currency
meaning it's trading on the stock market
and I am going to personally Drive the
value of that currency so rather than
paying me $1 today you could be paying
me 10 20 50 $100 tomorrow for every
dollar you pledge to me today and when
you're in Dave's position and you can
take that deal cuz he's been so
successful and he also um you know pen
it's all public so we'll talk about pen
gaming and ESPN and everything that did
there gave him his freedom back and
there are some things that happened
there so he's in a position that he can
go long on on Dave by going long on
Rumble now I'll give you another
perspective is it's okay let's look at
the Wall Street analyst wow so Rumble
doesn't have to use any of their
precious Capital they can keep building
infrastructure so they can scale up to
serve more viewers and more things with
their with their platform and they get
the benefit
of this individual okay well I wonder
what the delution is on the stock but
they're bringing more content that is
already proven and established you know
any dilution is is canceled by that
because we're increasing the value of
the hole and any retail investor you
know like me you whoever on the street
you look at it and you say wow now
there's more great content on that
platform so like when Sunday Ticket went
to um Direct TV back in the day 1994 it
really made Direct TV because it gave
you a reason to go to Direct TV because
there's great content content makes the
platform not the other way around and
you can already see the content that's
already been on Rumble now you've put
more content on top of that and the
market has had a value-driven very
positive reaction today congratulations
gr yeah that's a big deal so and by the
way for for for the audience that maybe
they're only YouTube right or uh uh even
X or maybe they consume their content
Tik Tok Instagram different places what
would you say is the biggest
differentiator between Rumble and
anything else that's out there whether
it's YouTube or
X so there's a lot of different
components uh I X is very different than
Rumble in in many different ways um and
you know I'll try to break that down
because it's uh I think it's important
for people to understand I don't see X
as competition at all the the one part
that we share is freedom of expression
allowing people to be authentic and
allowing people to to speak their minds
uh but in terms of the platform itself
X is a is a discovery platform so you
know if I'm on a discovery platform like
Tik Tok or x uh or Facebook or Instagram
you're going there to consume content
and you're going there to to find
content you don't have any particular
motive to go there when you're going to
YouTube or you're going to rumble on
YouTube's case DIY video you know
exactly what you're going to watch and
what you're trying to find when you're
going to rumble you know exactly who
you're going to you're going to reserve
like an hour to watch of the shows on
Rumble like Bonino or whoever it may be
um and you're going to reserve like one
full hour two hours you're not going
there to discover you're going there
with a high intention of watching
something very specific and you might
turn on your TV you might participate in
the chat and it's a very different
experience than uh when you look at X or
Tik Tok Facebook or or whatnot so um the
way I look at it is Rumble is very
intention-based and uh X Tik Tok and all
the other platforms are very uh dis
Discovery
non-intentional now now YouTube is is
much is much different um they're much
more like Rumble same like twitch uh you
have high intention even Netflix for
example is is closer to rumble than than
an X is and that's because of the it's
it all stems from the behavior they have
intention they they when you're going to
to YouTube you're watching the Patrick P
David podcast you're reserving an hour
to watch it you're not going there and
figuring it out you you already know
when he's going to go or you're getting
a notification when is going to go and
you see if you have time and you go
watch the full podcast the same the same
thing happens with Rumble now the
difference between YouTube and Rumble
there there's a lot of striking
differences one is obviously the you can
actually be authentic on on Rumble
whereas on YouTube authenticity
authenticity doesn't exist anymore they'
they've taken that out you can't have
conversations on numerous different
topics without some kind of repercussion
that's going to happen on the platform
whereas on Rumble you can be authentic
so people are going to come to rumble if
they want to really really see a really
true authentic experience and and have
content uh that you know they may agree
with or disagree with uh whereas on
YouTube You're Going to be much more
limited in what you're going to see and
you're not really sure if that person
that you're watching is being as
authentic so I think that's like a a a
glaring example um at 4:00 I'll tell you
a little bit more about uh what what we
have in store tomorrow but um that will
make a big difference against YouTube so
um that I I I was told I can't talk
about that that's all good I I want to
share something for for the viewers that
you're about to
be uh spooked when I tell you the story
about Rumble and I think you will be
spooked as well both you and Adam and
maybe even Tom can you pull up that
story real quick Rob on who was one of
one of the early investors in Rumble
it's a guy named Viv Viv Ramis Swani was
matter of fact New York Times broke the
story if you can go to the r one
investment seam at odds with his
position unwoke culture so can we see
the date on this uh when this was if we
can see the date on this store okay so
July 7 2023 we're talking about 6 months
ago go a little lower keep going lower
lower lower they're breaking all these
things down and then boom I think go up
go up where you see 25 million go up a
little bit more look for it there you go
but until you file these Financial
disclosures with election officials
there were few details the filing
reported that Mr Ramis Swami owned up to
$25 million investment in Rumble the
video platform Styles itself a refuge
for right-wing commentators shunt
elsewhere he owns up to $300,000 in
cryptocurrency primarily Bitcoin and
then all these other things so $25
million Viv Ramis wani is an investor in
Rumble and this was a quietly kept
secret I don't think anybody's talked
about this publicly but uh how did that
happen well first uh we're not a
platform for right-wing commentators New
York right wi yeah rightwing you're not
we're we're a platform for everyone uh
and you know we have sports leagues on
there we got bkfc we got UFC so I don't
know where they come up with that but
they they find their way you got to love
New York times's approach though they
come from a gentle approach and not
nonjudgment loving on crap up you just
with like for highly medicated so uh
yeah so VC was uh in our first public
round prior going public VC was part of
that um with naria capital and uh Peter
teal uh and he was one of the the larger
the larger investors and when we started
so and and that's with Peter the when
they came in yeah I think that was in
May of 2011 or April of 21 has does he
publicly talk about it I don't hear him
publicly talking about it no I haven't
heard do you know why why he doesn't
publicly talk it's he's got money behind
it he wins right I mean he like if if if
that's the number 32% essentially he
made 5 million today if that's the
investment that we're talking about
right 30 minimum 25 no at that age no
that 25 million is a bigger number it's
a much bigger number to him whatever
that 25 million is worth today but I've
not heard him talk about it do do you
and him communicate a lot you and uh VI
uh we we communicate um not a lot but we
do communicate I I stay in touch with
him quite frequently what do you think
about him as a the way he campaigned and
now some people are talking about
potentially VP I think Trump just
announced he's not going to be the VP
what do you think at him as a candidate
uh I think he he impressed a lot of
people I he he I he definitely caught
the eye of a lot of people and impressed
a lot of people and he did a lot better
than everyone thought he was going to do
so um I think that's impressive for for
anybody to pull you know over 5% in in
Iowa is a is a very impressive
impressive stat for somebody like that
to pull it yeah so anyways here you go
if you didn't know VI investor in Rumble
no but pretty interesting no post does
he post on Rumble yeah he's on Rumble as
well post let me let me tie in VC and
and Rumble and sort of what you know
kind of reacted to on this right what do
they what do they call it right here
right comment so uh I remember sitting
with you with pbd at the Republican
debates in Miami that's the debate where
vivec was like I'm calling on Ronda
McDaniel to step down right now Kristen
Welker you know he he basically did the
old office space you you
you you're cool all that same thing you
got something to say go there you go so
I'm sitting next to you you're on two
phones you're checking Trump's giving a
speech you're also sponsoring the RNC
like you got a lot going on I mean I
don't many phones you have today but
you're doing your thing so there's a
difference between perception and
reality I know you reacted real quick
you're like no we're not a right-wing
Refuge we're actually a free speech
platform Free Speech ironically enough
as mind-blowing it is kind of meets
rightwing these days which is weird so
and I remember you showing me the
percentage of breakdown of people that
are leftwing rightwing right Chris
you're actually it's a lot more in the
middle that you would suspect but
there's a difference between perception
and reality how do you avoid being
labeled even from the New York Times and
the media positioning Rumble oh those
right Wingers over there it's like the
reality is we're just a free speech
platform that should be left right
center up down how do you avoid that uh
that label it's it's a great question
and it's it's true the perception is not
the the perception is totally different
than the reality um the the data just
simply the data not by Rumble but by
comcore which is like the holy grail and
the advertising industry this is what
people spend their money behind so if
the data says this and it matches com
score advertisers put money behind it so
I'm guessing it's uh to them they think
it's right so the data has Democrats as
the number one category on
Rumble stop and think about that right
what there's right independ Independents
are second and Republicans are third
Independence and no affiliation combined
is the largest category on
Rumble I think you showed I think you
showed us I have it pinned on X at the
very top because I just want everybody
to see that because this pinned up top
on Rumble handle or on Twitter on
personalis can you go to Chris's
personal handle and show that I remember
you showing me these numbers and I think
it's important to talk for the for the
reputation of Rumble because if I asked
you hey who's on true social would it be
like oh it's the Maga people right who's
on parlor give me one second here okay
so if you look at this affiliation 12.6%
other 1.2 independent 28.9 Democrat
35.5 21.8 is Republican now who ran this
comcore ran this correct that's very
interesting to see data like that Q3
last year this no this yeah September
what is what is people's reaction when
you showed this they're they're thinking
80% is Republican right they don't
believe it it's that simple they don't
they they don't believe it but but like
there's a lot of things that have
happened on Rumble in the last year that
might have moved this number a lot um we
signed like massive creators we brought
in sports leagues um we brought on like
we brought on guys like kais senat and I
show speed to do a show we brought on DJ
academics to do a to a show these are
not political creators most of my
investment have not been political at
all um they've been in like various
different categories primarily sports
but we're talking about like the the
number one streamer on Twitch k at the
number one streamer on on YouTube I show
speed the number one guy in hip-hop
culture DJ academics like you bring all
these people onto the platform and you
bring on all these Sports League like
slap and SLS you're not going to have
like the the typical makeup of users
that you know that are tied to politics
so and there's also something to be said
is maybe people don't understand Mega
that well maybe people don't understand
what the mega composition really is as
well so like are are they all are they
all registered Republicans or a lot of
them Independents or a lot of them maybe
even Democrats who knows the magga crow
to make America great again well I mean
that's an easy question well no we're
definitely not Democrats well for sure
no I get that but like where where was
the voterbase where where where did they
do so well like where did Trump do so
well in 2016 Pennsylvania yeah the Rust
Belt the Rust Belt the typical blue wall
that were they registered Democrats 5 to
10 years ago no a lot of these guys
flip-flop four years they're the bipolar
part of the community traditionally
they've been the blue wall that that has
elected the Democrats and since Clinton
and and Obama correct but what are they
registered as a lot of times they're
independent there you go well that
that's in the data interesting so
Independence uh 35.5% Democrat I don't
think most people would have guessed so
who are some of the who were the biggest
if you were to give some numbers you
were to say these are the kind of users
we have this amount of traffic we're
getting every month when we're doing
lives we're getting this many many
viewers this is how many eyeballs here's
what the top content creators making
what are some numbers you can give us
well the biggest stream on Rumble every
single weekday is Dan Bonino and he's
posting over a 100,000 live every
morning at 11:00 a.m. and there is
nobody on stream charts that hits that
number every day nobody um it's unlike
anything I I I've ever seen the growth
on that channel alone has gone from 20
to 30,000 a year ago to a year later
doing I think he was at 115 120 this
morning of uh live streamers live
viewers I should say um and prior to him
you have Steven Crowder uh at the 10:00
hour who's just right up there at the
very close to 100,000 himself so you got
Crowder and then you got Bonino and then
um you have also Bandon that's running
in the same same we a lot of times in
the United States Rumble is one two and
three between 10 and 12 mhm which is
pretty significant and then obviously
some of the other big shows that we have
this is sort of counterintuitive what we
just discuss because those are the
biggest right wing talking guys in the
world so how does it fly in that data
that's what I'm saying that's what we're
trying to Grapple that's why people
assume you say Bonino you say Crowder
you say what was the third name Bannon
Steve Bannon hello that's not exactly
Democrat country right there so it's a
little weird how these numbers are
shaking out but that's the perception
versus reality but they're also not Al
like your typical Republican that you
you also see as well so like they're not
like you know you could see the stage
when at the debate there's only one VC
right everyone else was kind of saying
the same thing to a lot to a large
degree establishment versus disruptive
Force
right pretty much what what other data
do you have what what else what other
data you have with Rumble that's big
numbers to brag
about so we did 58 million active users
um which the majority of them are
happening in US and Canada I don't
remember the US and Canada number off
the top of my head but 58 million
globally that are that are happening on
the platform in the last recorder that
we reported um when you and it's over 30
million in US and Canada and when you
like stack that up against other
platforms out there I think it was close
to 40 million in US and Canada but don't
quote me on that um the last time x
reported their users in the United
States they the ma
the number that we use I think it was
like in 2019 and it was around 68
million in the US so like just YouTube
itself is around 200 million so when you
put our number against those numbers
like obviously we're not as big globally
not even close those there's huge
markets out there that we haven't really
penetrated at all but uh when it comes
to the US and Canada we're we're very
significant um so significant that I
think we have the largest streams out
there like when Kai and speed go live on
Rumble you know they there was one
stream where they did well over 200,000
people live like that's on a regular
they're like 50 to 100,000 and don't
Tates hold a record for like 450 or 4
what was the number they did yeah I
don't know if that was the I I would
have to look to see what the record is
but um yeah Tate Tates when he came back
it was around 430,000 in one
stream that that that's not like just
views that's live watching correct
430,000 lik watch very big can I can I
ask you one follow up on this so we we
we were talking about when we initially
met Chris or did that that sit down that
dinner it was two years ago he's like oh
was probably a year ago yeah we just
look right now it was February uh
February 9th of 22 when you made the
rogan1 million offer incredible which um
was was awesome so I remember you were
telling us your story about basically
the the humble beginnings of this and
the business platform but you didn't
realize how far extreme some of these
platforms are going to go and then just
left sort of a Blue Ocean strategy for
you as a free speech advocacy right so
there's a lot of entrepreneurs watching
this a lot of people are basically
trying to make business out of this you
just were creating a business model you
didn't foresee yourself being involved
in all this how surreal is it just pinch
yourself for the entrepreneurs that want
a dream that now we're talking about
YouTube Rumble uh Twitter X meta like
you're in this conversation Rumble where
3 years ago people were like Rumble what
does that mean like no knows like the
come up of an entrepreneur must be
really rewarding for you Chris yeah no
you know I remember when I was pitching
back in 2014 2013 they laughed me out of
the room laughed at me like they were
saying things that you know you can't
even say on you can't you cannot say it
on YouTube but on Rumble right now if
you want to hear what they were saying
but like the the VC Market was cruel
like super cruel and so but I went on I
I drove ahead I our politics by the way
in 2013 even till today like we don't we
don't have politics at Rumble like our
politics were cats and dogs if anything
when we started Rumble but uh it was
vicious trying to raise money and trying
to get to where we were and uh it is
really really rewarding to know that
you've gotten here without their help
you kind of did it without without all
them um that's like super rewarding when
you say they were vicious meaning they
didn't like the idea they wer P willing
to put money behind it oh was there a
was there a part where there was like
self-doubt that you were going to maybe
fold up shop the stuff they would say to
you in in in the meeting I there's one
particular meeting that stands out that
was so cruel and so like just basically
kicked me out um and uh you know it's
it's just really rewarding to know that
you you you won tell me who he is Chris
I'll kick his ass Chris what's the
biggest difference why you guys uh uh
are still around and growing doing deals
and parlor not
infrastructure um and this is a huge
thing about Rumble that I think is so
underappreciated uh of what we've done
so it it's also like an there's one
negative to building your own
infrastructure you got to move a lot you
move a lot slower on everything else
because like I can't just go to Amazon
and take something and build the
software on top I got to build the thing
that I would normally take from Amazon
and that's even harder than building the
software some would say you know like so
um what we've done is we've built our
own infrastructure from the ground up we
we were in data centers across the
country we have you know over points of
presence across the country um and we
don't rely in any meaningful way on any
of the big Tech infrastructure companies
um we're we're build we're we've built
it we've built the rumble Cloud um we're
anticipating to to release that Rumble
Cloud you know in in very short order um
and hopefully within this quarter um to
the public and um we that was the one
thing that that parlor didn't do is they
didn't build their infrastructure they
rented the infu they they took it from
Amazon they relied on Amazon and Amazon
pulled the plug and when I saw that
happen I said that's never going to
happen to us well I remember hearing
about AWS we all everyone knows Amazon
this isn't breaking news but I never
nobody really was too familiar with AWS
uh Andy Jazzy I link that's now the CEO
of um of Amazon he was the guy running
AWS they selected him to be the CEO but
they started pulling some stuff I think
it was a rumble was the was the onset of
this they said yeah AWS canceled them
basically took it down so you had the
forsight to say dude we're not even
messing with the AWS structure yeah we
never used AWS we used bare metal and we
rented things back then um but when this
happened we said we needed to own it uh
so now we own all our Hardware um we're
building our own network um and uh we
have a lot of clients already using it
now so like it's in beta you know people
that you might know Tim pool's whole
what business is on the websites on on
the rumble Cloud Rumble itself is is on
Rumble Cloud locals is on Rumble cloud
and uh hopefully we'll have bartool up
here they're going to be using they they
our deal includes the cloud as well so
and what was by the way now that's four
o00 you want to give everybody the
update on what the patent what the
announcements going to be yes so we
filed our first uh uh our first patent
so it's uh we're we're we're patent
pending right now and I think this is
like going to be a a massive Game
Changer uh that's going to happen we're
actually going to be releasing the
rumble Studio to the public uh
tomorrow um and one of the things it
that's really really important about
this patent and where I think uh Rumble
studio is going to change the game
something that YouTube does not have
something that um nobody has is is we're
going it's not going to be released
tomorrow but Rumble Studio itself will
released but a part of Rumble studio
will be the automatic bidding of live
reads within the studio so imagine this
for a second it it it sounds complicated
but it's actually pretty simple imagine
you're Coca-Cola imagine you know you're
the Patrick Bet David podcast and you're
the Creator you're using Rumble Studio
to stream to X we will be supporting X
by the way we'll be supporting YouTube
we'll be supporting twitch
um and we'll be supporting other
platforms through custom rtmp as well
but you're streaming to multiple
platforms using the rumble studio um and
then all of a sudden you get a
notification that says hey Coca-Cola
want or Coca-Cola wants to buy an
indorsement or sponsorship on your
podcast and they're willing to pay X at
that very given moment that's what this
is that that's where Rumble studio is
going to go we're we want to build it
not only just the Studio to live stream
but an ad platform that can help
creators make money across any live
streaming platform um and if you're
Coca-Cola imagine how awesome it is to
be able to go into the rumble
advertising Center and say hey I have a
$10,000 budget I want to advertise on
these categories um and I will pay five
cents a live viewer not not an not a
view that you know can be manipulated or
whatnot that uh but like a a live viewer
an actual person watching like you're
paying for that live viewer so all the
incremental views you get P after that
you know is bonus to The Advertiser so
they can put the parameter in pick the
channels they want to go on or pick on
run on network and then pick a budget
they want to do and then the
notification goes in real time to to all
the streamers using the studio that's
where I think we we change the game for
live streaming um right now the entire
video Market is uh is propped up on
programmatic Advertising pre-rolls
commercials that start at the beginning
of uh of um of your videos or Midway
through your videos uh this will have
talent endorsing product if the talent
agrees to accept it for the offer that
the advertiser provides that's a big
deal that especially to be able to do it
the uh instant real time uh guys doing a
live stream and boom yes let's accept
this read this boom here's money that
goes into the account so it's more than
just a a Super Chat option that you're
going to have it's a big deal with
you're what you're putting together with
the rumble yeah it's and it's something
that you know we're protecting cuz we
think this is such a big idea like we've
we obviously run live reads with a lot
of creators now we know how successful
it is it it converts and performs for
advertisers far better than programmatic
ads do so we we think we're on to
something really big and and the beauty
of it's not limited to just Rumble we'll
be making money with the creators across
all platforms I love it and and you know
one of the things I was saying during
lunchtime is the following one is when
you're on YouTube YouTubers are not uh
uh uh necessarily going around say well
if I ask you right now what YouTube
stands for values and principles you
wouldn't be able to tell me what YouTube
stands for think about it if I ask you
what YouTube stands for you wouldn't be
able to say it if I ask you what Twitter
stands for you would be able to say it
freedom of speech there's certain values
because you would think about what you
would think about the founder right what
they stand if I ask you right now what
Google stands for you wouldn't have an
answer if I ask you what Facebook stands
for maybe you would say collecting your
data right honestly you would think
about collecting your data if I ask you
what Tik Tok stands for maybe you would
say brainwashing your kids in America
while keeping the kids in China smart
right maybe you would say that and
whether there's credibility in that or
not there's been proofs on some people
I've looked at it where there is
credibility in that taking place but go
ahead and talk to a guy that's a rumble
content creator look how they are
they'll wear the shirt they'll wear the
hat and they'll say rumble stands for
freedom of speech and if I told you we
get a hundred messages a week when are
you guys joining Grumble when are you
guys doing this I don't even understand
why you're not you're you're such a a
person like you you have the money come
down to rumble I get these messages all
the time you know all I think about all
I think about is the people that are
there respect and value what you built
and it's a beautiful thing to see that
they respect the app that's been build
and it's growing that's getting the
attention of people like Dana White and
Dave por no and Dave porno bringing all
their apps over to you but guys if
you're listening to this Tom you look
like you want to say something so before
I go to the next story I want to come to
you no I was just I was going to
compliment with what you did because I
think in adte you're you're really
crossing over a chm here there have been
people a lot of people have wanted make
hey we're going to make the and I I saw
this business plan in
2013 to be exact hey we're going to make
the eBay for product insertion product
placement and um the movies product
placement is always done by the big
agencies right peragon was a Pioneer in
that you know William Morris Endeavor
Etc no no we're going to let you do
spontaneous episodical product placement
and it's like wait a minute and we're
going to make the eBay of that so
there's a lot of people that had early
adtech things but it really wasn't adte
it was just dis remediating the um uh
the agents out of it and it was wreaking
havoc on the ad sales on the network
because how can you do product placement
for you know say a Coca-Cola product and
then say by the way tell ad sales we
can't sell Pepsi this week cuz we're
doing spontaneous product placement what
you're bringing forward in this is sort
of a spontaneous you know um Marketplace
and an adte solution which I think is
pretty clever so you know have to thatw
thank you so if you're listening Rumble
Community uh uh shout out to you guys
congrats this is a big day for everybody
in the rumble Community you ought to be
celebrating all over the place on
Twitter whatever stories that's being
posted share the stories that he's
posting and let everybody else screaming
off the top your lungs on the big uh big
day that you guys had today that's the
reflection of a Founder that's
constantly growing to grow the business
it's very very hard to have something
like that but I think you I even told
you two years ago you're the right guy
to do a job like this and you've grown
it's a multi-billion company now and for
some of you that have been following the
man caucus right the man caucus is the
voting that started okay Rob do you have
both of them first we'll start off with
this and we'll go to the next one
everyone wants to know who won
it was a very very close race on who was
going to get the $2,000 suit here's what
the numbers look like as of right now
Vinnie when we started a contest he only
had 103 man Adam was at 572 Tom was at
291 today Adam is at 855 only 145 away
from a thou I think Tom may get to thou
it's a race to see who's going to get to
a thou first Adam's at 283 on this
campaign Tom went from 291 to
779 catching up to sauce but sauce is
cool sauce is like it's all good 488 is
where Tom's at and Vinnie went from 103
to
555 minut Vinnie
wins the Flippin suit and not only that
with all the mans that he did last week
I think he got 400 reviews on your uh uh
man account I don't how many five star
reviews you got people love you on man
uh and that means we have to go buy
Vinnie a nice $2,000 suit
congratulations Vinnie all the support
out there uh uh that you came out we had
a record-breaking downloads of the app
record-breaking number of people booking
man Vinnie I think how much did man pay
you last week just you know Consulting
and talking to people on on the app well
I want to say thank you to everybody
that was out there it it was some were
just like beat Adam some was like beat
Tom but then some were very serious some
were I'm listening to you talking you're
in crying talking to somebody C cried
multiple time I'm at 45 the
testosterone's gone I'll cry right now
um but I'll B I don't I'll wear my heart
my sleep whatever the chest whatever
anyway but um what was that what was the
question manck what how much did the app
pay you less we just part-time answering
questions here and there no joke I got
paid well one day I got
$5,600 in a day in a dayet and you know
me I've never had that much money so
guess what I went to the dollar store I
went in there and just was like let's go
toilet paper all the liver you bought a
bunch of prote I've been trying to get
Vinnie to I've been trying to help
Vinnie go from a to an investor
for nooice saying when Vinnie came in I
gave him a whole well I don't want to I
don't want to stay on this too long all
I want to say is Vinnie congrats to you
and yang while you're watching this
there's a lot of different updates
that's coming on as well and Rob if you
want to pull up to the other one if you
like the man Chris is officially on man
if you have any questions about building
a company technology growing the
business founder and his family guy you
know and he's
Canadian and an American from Toronto
lives in Florida and there's a lot of
different things that you can learn from
someone like that as well listen we had
a convers he doesn't get political
doesn't get political and I get it but
from looking at that photo who's that
little rascal behind him who is that
when you that Rascal who's saying he's
getting political just so happens that b
is sitting behind you that's not getting
political there he is it's just he's
just you know basic watching the UFC
fight what's wrong with that I'm glad
I'm glad you noticed that Vinnie because
I'm like dude your your your picture he
a good off he a good looking guy show
The Mug Chris so if you got any
questions for anybody by the way Chris
Chris put your he put his man rate at 50
bucks are you kidding me like just go
ask the man a question on man and uh I'm
sure he's got a lot of value to bring to
you guys but a lot of people are joining
man left and right I want to start off
by congratulating Vinnie and on top of
that we have more contests coming up
this Friday I have a merch drop I'm
doing that has to do with the late Kobe
Bryan stay tuned I'm so excited about
that one uh but stay tuned till Friday
we'll make that announcement anyways
let's get right into it congratulations
question for you Chris here's a question
for you question for you as a Canadian
okay proud Canadian right and you live
in Toronto you're from Canada and when I
listen to you I catch the Canada you
know some of the stuff that you guys do
I had a friend of mine have a friend of
mine when I would go to his place he
would we would drink cocy together what
COC however way you guys pronounce your
beer how do you pronounce that
uh Canadian beer Tom's drinking it right
now cocy Cy have you heard about this
moose head no I'll find it I'll find
what it's called anyways so yeah it's
more like cocaine is what it was is what
you're were saying Tom's into that Vibe
but but Rob can you pull up what just
happened at the UFC fight this week I I
I don't want you to get offended or
upset you know Tom how do you guys feel
that at the UFC fight this is what fans
Canadians were chanting it is a little
bit offensive so just please bear for
imp impact Rob go Ahad and play this
clip go
ahead you know my English isn't that
good but I think what was that French
what they what do Rob what are they I
know they were doing the let's go
Brandon of Canada right now so what
Vinnie Adam what were they saying they
were saying Trudeau how how do you
feel about you know saying something
like that about your prime
minister you know it's it's interesting
cuz like I think you guys are a little
softer up here yeah down here I should
say and then up there we're we're pretty
vulgar way America is softer than Canada
hold on really okay wait CU I you guys
let's go Brandon versus that well they
were saying Joe Biden and then he's
like oh let's go Brandon I think that
was the news reporter that was right it
was a she's like oh how do you feel
about the fact that everybody's chanting
driver's name was the driver's name was
Brandon and he's all like I don't think
that's what such a long time Rob it's
worth playing the clip again the
original you know she like what are they
what are they saying no she thought they
were saying let's go Brandon the
driver's like yeah it's a race that's a
NASCAR race if you talk but go ahead how
do you feel about seeing UFC fight
chanting like this Chris well you know
as I was saying earlier I don't like to
get too too deep into the politics
myself so um you know just listen to it
it's uh it was uh it was very
interesting to see now Trudeau obviously
he's done a lot of a lot of things I
don't agree with in in Canada a lot of
the bills bill C11 that he was trying to
pass was you know the things that it was
originally proposing was crazy in in my
eyes so a lot of things I just don't
agree with would it be fair to say that
Justin Trudeau is the male version of
AOC in Canada or like the actual stepson
of a Bernie Sanders maybe even a Fidel
Castro kind of a thing where would you
say for the people in America you know
soft Americans over here right Chris
where would you say that Justin trudo is
is most like on the political
Spectrum Canadians are very left um but
they're also you know I think the
spectrum is is quite wide in Canada like
we did you saw the truckers protest you
saw the things Canadians would fight for
so I I think there's like a there's it's
very diverse in the sense that it it
goes very left and right but why are
Canadians very left is it is it the
weather it's cold and you have you have
you have you have three major parties
you have the NDP you have the Liberals
and you have the conservatives um the
Liberals uh are supposed to be the
center in the center uh but what you see
liberals but what you see happening is
like the conservatives actually I think
they had the popular vote I think they
got like close to 40% of the vote plus
you know the PPC as well had another 5%
so almost half a Canada voted
conservative but the Liberals have power
and the way the way that the Liberals
have power is they have to do deals with
the far-left in Canada the NDP so I
think that's what pulls them uh in that
direction um and that's why you see the
way it is and then also you have Justin
Trudeau what do you what do you think
about Pierre po poier or however way you
pronounce his last name do he does he
have a shot at competing and being a PM
or
no I I think like there's I can't see
any way that NDP or the Liberals win the
next election I just cannot see that
happening if that happens I just would
be shocked I was shocked they actually
won the last one so well how do how does
someone like cuz and I'm being dead
serious like over here in America it's
okay Biden he he's safe and then you get
the Maga and then I have yet to meet one
person and I'm not from all the manors
from people at parties that you know the
every single person that I've met Chris
from Canada is absolutely disgusted with
what tro is and what he's doing and I
keep asking him like why do you guys why
is he in when's he going to get out
when's the next election why why why
does everybody dislike this guy
literally everybody I think it's just a
Litany of different things that are
embarrassing uh to Canadians like the
just the push back you know obviously in
my world on on freedom of expression in
Canada is uh is like a major concern
like Freedom expression is in is Article
19 of the UN Human Rights Declaration of
Human Rights Charter Article 19 freedom
of expression it's like super important
it's
it's super important for everybody it's
part it's a human right and like when
you have a government and that's pushing
back against freedom of expression that
alone is is going to is going to piss
off a lot of people that that's just one
thing there's there's a whole Litany of
different things that he's done but uh
you know just on that topic alone
because that's really relevant to what I
do is super embarrassing to see the
stuff that they've done on uh not
upholding freedom of expression like
that's a basic human right that everyone
needs to adhere to period there should
be no questions asked you if you lose
freedom of expression you lose your
battle to fight for anything
ever that's how important it is yeah
we're we're on the same page with that
while we're at this UFC thing Rob can
you play the clip with Dana White oh you
found the our friend here I don't we
just wrap this up it's a very emotional
moment from the past and Americans will
appreciate it thank you to all of our
partners oh my God it's just such a
unbelievable moment
Brandon you also told me as you can hear
the chance from the the
crowd let's go Brandon you told me you
were going to kind of hang back those
first two stages and just watch and
learn what even he's confused like what
wrong with you found out that Miss South
Carolina if you remember that she found
a job Rob play this clip so here it is
you know this is following up with
Strickland when he gets up there and
tells us reported when he's asking a
question saying hey would you be okay if
your son was gay so you never want to be
a grandfather I don't have a problem
with that and he says you know just 10
years ago when he asked him about
budlight he says 10 years ago being
transgender was a mental disorder what
happened to you what's wrong with you
guys right and then he asks the question
I believe it may be the same reporter
maybe it's another person asks Dana this
question go ahead and play the clip I
get tell on theone like you obviously
give a Long Leash to your Fighters about
you know what they can say when they are
up there with a UFC microphone and you
getting into territory homophobia
transphobia like is there I don't give
anybody a leash well I'm saying you a
leash I'm like free
speech control what people say going to
tell people what to believe going to
tell people I don't tell any
other human being what to say what to
think and there's no leashes wow on any
of
them what is your
question I was asking that question I'll
move on though yeah probably a good idea
that's ridiculous to say I give somebody
a leash Free Speech Brother people can
say whatever they want and they can
believe whatever they
want what a what a beautiful POS how is
this position controversial today Vinnie
well controversial because think every
everybody's owned like the NFL is owned
by you know all these different people
but good good Dells in front of it
because they're selling to America the
fans of the UFC love that type of
attitude they love this type of guy did
you see what Sean Strickland was in he
was in Canada in front of that you know
the pre press conference they he showed
love to Canada and they were going
absolutely nuts for but Patrick that
right there Dana White that's you were
at the press conference I was at the one
was Strickland yeah well he was they
were going crazy from the kid ran up on
what did the guy look like the reporter
asking a question did he look like a
regular guy everyone look yeah no no but
did he look like did he have like a
rainbow beanie on Al was at the press
conference where the kid came onto the
stage I wasn't at the press conference
on the prior day okay I got you but
don't you want to work like think about
this cuz while that while that's
happening while that's going on Dana
White's just standing there at the
podium not saying anything that's a
grown man he has his own voice like
people are like well it's a bad
reflection of UFC guess who the UFC's
fill of guys that are trying to kill
each other like it's all right let them
go but why even get into this topic
we're we're at a sporting event like why
are these reporters even going there
what's the relevance to to
Sean Strickland and asking these
questions like because all the other
sports are going to rap can you pull out
what the NHL just announced they're
doing have you seen what NHL is doing no
go
NHL uh and hockey stick what do you call
it when you put a tape around wrapping
the tape around the type in NFL NHL
hockey stick lgbtq okay type in NHL
hockey stick lgbtq so can they is there
a video you can show I mean if you go at
this point Twitter doesn't work that way
way okay yeah look at that so they're
they're putting stick they're putting
that wrap around all all of them yeah so
so then to the point where they have to
sit there and talk about whether we keep
this we ban this so every sport nowadays
is trying to promote lgbtq so you know
why why why you know to to their eyes
the reporter's eyes you know uh uh uh
Dana how come you know you are allowing
your guys to talk the way they do
because it's Reckless you know Sean
Strickland shouldn't be talking like
that that's what the reporter is
thinking about right of course so to to
the reporter's eyes it's normal they
like to put a leash on people the same
people that are anti-slavery they're PR
leashes tell me how that makes any sense
explain that to me Mr reporter educated
guy that probably went to Columbia
University how are you anti-slavery but
you're Pro PR leash what's the big
difference it's the same exact thing
yeah but you just want him to agree with
you and that's just not Dana's Amo
Dana's not going to do that yeah he's
he's a guy that's going to sit there and
say guys you guys want to say what you
want to say there could be consequences
behind it good luck go ahead that's
called freedom of speech it comes with
consequences exact got to respect a guy
like that I love it speaking of like
sort of double standards you brought up
the United Nations I'm not trying to
throw you involved in in anything
geopolitical right now but you brought
up the 19th provision what is it part of
the you I believe article of the
Declaration of Human Rights which is
interesting because I I what I what I
respect about Rumble is that you're a
free speech absolutist right you believe
in free speech here's article 19
everyone has the right freedom of
opinion an expression this this right
includes freedom to hold opinions
without interference and to seek receive
and impart information ideas through any
meting regardless of Frontiers I think
we can fully agree upon that in America
Canada but when you look at the list of
countries that are part of the United
Nations a vast majority of the countries
of the United Nations they don't allow
freedom of expression whether it's Cuba
whether it's Afghanistan whether it's
freaking in Romania I don't know our
friend Tate is sitting in a jail C it's
on house arrest CU he can't say what he
wants to say they on Rumble nonetheless
oh China um China I don't know if
they're part of the United Nations no
doubt Iran Russia so again not getting
you involved in geopolitics but we're
talking about double standards here and
people talking out both sides of their
mouth yeah I wish that they lived up to
this it's a human right that's the part
that like gets me when you really
realize this is like a human right you
know everyone talks about human rights
well free expression like free speech is
a human right you need that you need
that for for any society that's going to
you know for any kind of society that's
going to push back on anything like how
did we how do the Civil Rights movements
happen how do all how do women's rights
movements happens it all stems from Free
Speech the ability to express yourself
and push back to try to make things
better period you can never get rid of
that you get rid of that you get rid of
all Freedom like that's that's where it
goes and that's not acceptable and you
look at what happened in Harvard after
everything with the Dei and all the uh
Congressional testimonies Harvard dead
last I don't if you can pull this up Rob
dead last in freedom of speech and
freedom expression of of any University
in the country
Harvard like how is that even possible
so it's happening not only in Iran and
in Russia but it's also happening on
Harvard stown out here Harvard get I got
a question for you I got a question for
you say you have kids today okay and say
your kid is I'm actually curious to what
you're going to say he's 17 years old
she's 17 years old smart like you
schooling 4.3 GPA let's just say Okay
SATs out of 1600 they each get 1450
just pick and choose who you got would
you support your kids going to a Harvard
today well I think if you can get into
Harvard you capitalize on that
opportunity but I would think that most
kids I've said this a million times we
talked about this with Candace Owens
most kids should not just go directly
into college I think there should be
some sort of whether it's mandatory or
obligatory or Freedom most kids should
have to do one year community service
your eyes in your eyes even in your eyes
as much as you're trashing them if your
kid was accepted to go to Harvard you
would say you should never say no to
Harvard so Tom I want to come to you
here Harvard any of those higher
institutions of learning you should
consider aend learn let me ask you a
question here's a question for and by
the way let let me explain to you why
this is so important
Tom your daughter gets a 1560 ons SATs
out of 1600 I don't know if you guys are
at a point right now where you're
announcing or you're comfortable talking
about the school she got in or not
that's up to you you tell me if you're
comfortable or not okay because I think
it's final right okay fantastic so you
didn't and you guys for five years I've
heard you talk and you would say pen pen
pen she could she had a ticket to go to
pretty much any school in America 4.6
GPA 4.56 GPA 1560 on sats out of 1600
golf involved smart giving back she's
she's a leader amongst leaders but but
you told me the other day you guys
didn't even choose to apply for her to
go to University of Pennsylvania warten
when did you guys make the decision to
say nope the name doesn't matter as much
as it did 5 10 years ago well things
anybody that um follows the calendar
when you're the end of junior year you
have all your testing and everything
comes down now you put all that together
yeah and then the very beginning of
senior year the applications go in and
Ed which um doesn't mean that big fun no
no it means early decision and you'll
get a decision back from the University
by December 15th if you say if you
accept me I I will enroll in your
University so that's an ed application
it it's it gives you a higher chance of
going in so all those decisions are made
on or around September 15th October 1st
okay and you're clicking the mouse and
putting it in there and you're correct
we've been looking at at pen Wharton for
a long time Wharton undergrad also has a
minor in entrepreneurship and then but
Tom you didn't apply there why didn't
you apply there we I I'm just looking
for that answer because I I was alarmed
I was alarmed of what was happening I
was I'm sorry I was taking to long
you're giving me like a college planning
for my kids I'm just asking I'm just
looking up Ed at this point in my life I
don't want that as the excessive level
look you knew college campuses were
liberal but as the excessive wave of of
wokeness was coming across I was looking
at it and I'm like we're not doing that
you know we're we're sorry we're we're
not doing that and and by the way six
weeks after we make the decision in the
middle of the Ed window what happens in
front of the Congressional hearing it's
like well there you go there's the
president was that the decision you guys
made you have a choice Tom we have a
choice and we chose we pulled back from
you pull back from Wharton and you
you put your kid your daughter in and
she also had a a selected major she
wanted to study Sports analytics stem
and she wanted to study sport management
double major and she picked the best
best college in the country for that can
I say it or you keeping a absolutely
Rice University where she was going
which is exciting yeah she got accepted
early
decision we weren't Aspen when the de
when the was it the dean or who was it
that spoke the president that spoke to
her no the dean yeah the dean of the
college yeah you know when the last time
a dean of a college spoke to me probably
on a
we had him on here as a guest there is
no talking to us because Tom we don't do
stuff like this Tom look at me we don't
do stuff like this yeah the what I'm
saying rob you understand what I'm
saying I make it very clear because
that's just a unique community that
knows what this mean people like us we
think you're doing this as like a dance
or maybe like you know different kind of
gang signs you're throwing let me let me
flip it on you people because you got
four kids here we go well I was I was
just at our friend Keith's house for
Thanksgiving right one of his nephews
he's awesome Cavs huge Cavs doing his
thing you know he's flying on his
private jet to ASP and doing his things
thanks Keith um one of his nephews was
there absolute stud and Keith went to
Cornell major Hospitality school do you
know the hospitality industry thinking
Community yeah okay exactly that's big
in the hospitality but he also got
accepted University of Florida
University of Florida is run by now Ben
sass who was a former Senator Nebraska I
believe the point is this he's actually
deciding between not going to
Cornell um which is number one for this
particular particular field and going to
Florida even though it's you know Ben
sass is very kind of spoke out about
this but the point is I think where
you're going is that people are now
maybe not considering going to pen and
they're going to go to Rice people are
not considering not going to cor Cornell
and they're considering going to
University of Florida when you have kids
we all know that Dylan's going to get
some sort of sports thing and uh and and
Tico's gonna be directing movies and and
uh Santa's gonna be cheerleading and
Brooklyn's gonna be uh cholo dancing you
know what she's going to Lean Like A
Cholo specific that's her favorite song
right now how are you going to process
what schools to to send your kids to and
what advice do you have for the people
out there cuz if your kids getting into
Harvard you got to consider that no no
not for me when I saw that day I'm
telling you I said it to the face of the
doctor that was here you know Josh John
Abramson we had a very good conversation
with him and he is a guy that sits on
the you know one of the boards in
Harvard I said the day in Harvard when I
was at the OPM program when I saw what
they did when Hillary and Trump were
campaigning I was in Harvard that day I
was in school for 3 weeks for an
executive education program and I saw
100% of professors at Harvard were
rooting for Hillary not one was rooting
for Trump I realize that school doesn't
believe in debate no they believe in uh
uh get locked into one side of the
community and that's it they do not
believe in debate and that's when I'm
like now my kids they need to go to a
place where it's at least 50/50 I want
to be at a place where it's 50-50 where
we can get both sides of the argument
and you learn if you know how to debate
on process issues by then we would make
the decision now Dylan doesn't want to
go to college because Dylan wants to go
play sports straight he just wants to go
straight and play you know he wants to
go Manchester United he wants to
obviously he's 10 years old he you know
yesterday he was doing a baseball try
we'll see what's going to happen with
that Dylan's saying that today Tico
wants to take a year off before he goes
to college I love him he says I want to
work for you know doing certain things
and then seeing if I even need to go to
college then I will smart now the kid is
11 years old you know how much is going
to change the next seven years he's got
an uncle like Tom Elward you know he's
going to have these guys that are going
to talk to him but for us yes we are
very protective of no debate we believe
in debate I'm not going to send my kids
to a place that there is zero debate
taking place and it's all one-sided
that's not that's not going to be
beneficial for them so no I wouldn't be
doing it I'm not turned on by Harvard
what they're doing I think it's a
show there I think they've lost
credibility I think it's absolute insult
to debate in any University that you
consider yourself a university yet you
know the the debate is taking place and
US students are sitting there watching
you're only clapping 300 people who are
working that they're only clapping for
Hillary not one person was voting for uh
uh rooting for Trump I don't need you to
root for Trump but I need you to be 5050
60 40 for us to but how how do you
change that at this point you saw that
they fired claudian gay the the
president of school they've done the
same thing with pen she you got Bill
Amman out there you know putting his
money against it does it come down to
basically the big donors and the
endowment people being like you I'm
out look it's not a light switch you
know you it's not a flip of a switch
it's not a vote it's and anything like
that it is so ingrained and
indoctrinated I mean you even see
there's some well-intended efforts that
are going on you can go to pen
forward.com there's a lot of professors
that are out there putting their name on
a position and say the pen needs to get
back to the following things you know um
you know University neutrality you know
fostering civil debate from both sides
tolerance understanding that the price
of free speech is Free Speech that's the
price of free speech is free speech is
hearing something that that you may not
like and there's laws against incenting
riots and Civil Disobedience but there
is no law against Free Speech but now
there's all these mores and folkways and
things that people are trying to enforce
on it but Tom you're going to hurt
people's feelings talking like that
that's the whole point no Tom you can't
hurt people's feelings liberalism is
based on feelings no Chris you got a
family how do you process this so I was
uh I went to University of Toronto and I
dropped out um yeah
so I'm not a huge advocate of the of the
whole school system to begin with uh I
think it was like second or third year I
was building internet websites back in
20002 2001 and I uh started making good
money doing that and uh saw no need for
for the school I I was always against it
too like I I never really kind of liked
that that way of learning I was always
more of a self-teacher kind of
researching and doing things on my own
and uh
the politics involved with it now has
just gone to a point where I it was I
was annoyed at it back then I can't even
imagine right now so not an advocate for
it I I think uh the real world teaches
you bigger lessons and more lessons and
you learn a lot more out there uh doing
real things than than going and sitting
in front of a teacher that's going to
tell you what to think at this point of
your life is there anything Harvard can
do to get you to go back to college I I
think like seeing Harvard on your resume
is
like I I does not do anything for yeah I
mean
look it's interesting to say that
because For the Longest Time all we
thought about was what har right we
listen we got a couple Harvard guys here
I was just going to say we got some
friends Ser we got a couple har guys
here let's not a bull ring in his nose
and he he has green hair and he's like
we're all just different whatever dude
no no but but the point is but the point
is it's funny that today's leaders at
Harvard have changed the reputation of
what it maybe once was that I wouldn't
know about because when I think about
Harvard or some of these schools you
think debate I judge a great school
based on debate if you don't have the
ability to reason in a school as a
professor you're not a college it's lip
service you just get this is why when we
had the great um Joe Jorgenson legendary
podcast what you laughing about oh I'm
sorry I just it was the my bad Jo Joe
jensson on I mean you only ruined her
entire career on that day that's not
called me ruining matter of fact you
know what if you want to bring it up Rob
go ahead and bring it up this is what
college will do to you sometimes pull up
YouTube and go type in Jorgenson and
type in B David have you ever seen this
or no I've seen it okay I have to see it
again now the greatest I don't know why
you guys brought it up why would Chris
bring this up I mean we've already over
Chris brings it up right now not
necessary Chris to do that but goad go
ahead and open this up go ahead and open
this up right so so there's Tony okay no
that's Manalapan by the way you can tell
from the house that's beautiful
Manalapan house okay go back a little
bit and watch the question being asked
this is what happens go all the way to
the beginning and press play and Rob I
give you permission to play this ask
sure who have you debated who's been
your toughest debate
[Music]
ever I
mean that's 10 seconds already I didn't
feel that any of my debates were tough
I've don't
I I'm
yeah he killed it that's our president
right there in 1996 I was in the third
party debate when I debated the green
party Constitution party and and those
uh in March before the
nomination I was also in a third party
debate where I sat next to the green
party um nominee and a few other people
and then of course the debates within
the libertarian part party but when's
the last time you had a really tough
debate against a non-
Libertarian when is the last well it was
it was pretty easy uh debating the Green
Party candidate that's for sure um
so yeah let me continue when is the last
time you had a debate with a non-
Libertarian or non- green party when is
the last time you had a debate with
somebody that was non libertarian non
Green Well an official debate like I
said it would be in the
it's going to go like this for a few
minutes what were you going for with
that right there just showing that she
just doesn't debate no what I'm going
with this is these liberal universities
that don't have any debate they're no
longer universities all they are is
somebody's coming up to give a speech
and they go home that's it and these
professors don't get pushed because God
forbid you push them they go in an echo
chamber and everybody agrees with
everybody yesterday I'm on a Twitter Rex
okay and perfect transition into this
and this is minutes after after Ronda
Sanz steps down suspends his campaign
and he endorses president Trump okay so
I get a message from Mario Neal hey
would you be willing to do a Twitter
spaces live right now I thought it was
going to be 1015 minutes an hour later
I'm still on having a conversation with
these guys questions being asked and
everybody was pushing what about this
and what about that and what about it's
the debate disc course it's risk cuz
it's open anybody can ask any questions
and it was phenomenal because either I'm
wrong or I'm right but I'm going to give
you my views and you make a decision for
what you want to do can you play the
clip of Ronda santz announcing that he
is no longer going to be campaigning and
again I'm not trying to be funny or
disrespectful I have not seen this man
this happy in eight months okay and
relieved go ahead and play this look how
happy he looks but I can't ask our
supporters to volunteer their time and
donate their resources if we don't have
a clear path to Victory accordingly I am
today suspending my campaign I'm proud
to have delivered on 100% of my promises
and I will not stop now it's clear to me
that a majority of Republican primary
voters want to give Donald Trump another
chance they watch his presidency get
styed by Relentless resistance and they
see Democrats using lawfare this day to
attack him I've had disagreements with
Donald Trump such as on the Corona virus
pandemic and his elevation of Anthony
fouchy Trump is superior to the current
incumbent Joe Biden that is clear I
signed a pledge to support the
Republican nominee and I will honor that
pledge he has my endorsement because we
can't go back to the old Republican
guard so we have a nice conversation you
know I don't know if I agree with this I
don't know if I agree with that this
tulsy thing I don't like trump it was
awesome it was phenomenal that's the
beautiful thing about having people you
can have a conversation that you can
agree with that is my number one reason
why I don't support today's educational
system is because there's no debate
everybody has to everybody who sits
together and say s there and they agree
and that's it you know we bring people
here from the left from the right my
favorite conversations sometimes are
people I disagree with literally my
favorite conversation of all are people
I disagree with we dis I mean think
about it he doesn't see the same as me
he doesn't like if you're just sitting
there everybody's kissing each other's
butt in it's Echo chamber where are we
how are we moving forward nobody's
bumping heads to figure it out because
that they're going to think they're the
way that they're going to think you're
going to way they're let's go into this
thing so what so thoughts on the santis
stepping down you know and how he did it
and you know obviously a lot of people
are saying what could he have done
differently and all this stuff I'm not
here to talk about that we talked about
that on the last podcast now that he
stepped down endorsing Trump doing what
he's doing uh what do you think he's
going to be doing next himself uh Ronda
santz do you think he'll be out there
well we'll see him before November him
and Trump on stage to get an actual like
a endorsement endorsement or he's
thinking this is the closest he's going
to get to Trump I kept my commitment I
signed the pledge I'm doing this and
this is
it it's a good question question um will
he get on the stage with
Trump I I think so you think he will
yeah
okay you're you're pretty optimistic
that that's going to happen okay yeah
okay go ahead I was gonna say one thing
about uh the Santa you want to tell me
you want to go first I'll I'll give me
get my thoughts real quick I'm 75% that
he'll get on stage because he's got to
line up with it he's got a lot of donors
that are going to say Ron come on come
back Ron come come back home and let's
and let do this and I think there's 75%
chance that he would be on stage doing a
thumbs up on a line there at the
convention standing behind the candidate
I look at this two ways shortterm and
long-term shortterm um he made a
decision to run to the right of trump he
saw him when he'd go on that paperwork
and he said this is how we're going to
get beat him we can't beat him from the
left Nikki Haley on the other hand has
made a decision to run in a more
moderate corporate left of trump so and
we we kind of busted her proverbial
balls uh when we see she said it's it's
a two-man race at this point that was
after Iowa when she finished third
reality is it is a two-man race because
we said on the podcast here Friday ago
Ron's got three more days until he drops
out or it's going to be 30 more days
turns out boom he dropped out in two
days breaking news on Sunday morning so
where what do I mean by this Nikki's
still in it I think she's going to be
finished after New Hampshire it's going
to be abundantly clear that by South
Carolina comes back which is in uh mid
to late February and the 20th I believe
if she doesn't win her home state she's
done she's finished but she might take
some of Ronda Sanchez vote what I think
is good for Dan santis long term in 2028
once Trump finishes his presidency if he
is that guy this time he can position
himself right neck and neck with ramas
Swami now we all know that we like ramas
Swami a little bit better than benron
but the numbers show a different thing
more people are willing to vote for
Ronda Sanders at this point but Maga the
Republicans the conservatives the people
who make up the base they are officially
done with Nikki she's pandered the
Democrats she's pandered The
Independents we'll see how that works
out in New Hampshire but Nikki is done
if it doesn't work out in 2024 which I
don't think it will but Des sandz has a
chance in 2028 I think I think this
reconfirmed my initial assessment which
was especially with how happy he was cuz
at the beginning of this video he was he
was glowing with happiness because we
fast forward it that his wife I think
his wife or somebody pretty sure it was
her that was like you can do it you're
going to run Trump is going to get
arrested they're going to indict him
he's going to be in jail and that was
the that was the honey in his ear that's
your I can't wait for Rhonda Sanders to
pull Will Smith on you and say keep my
wife's name out your mouth guess what I
swing back though but anyway um but look
look hold on Pat can can you show look
at look how happy that little Gipper is
look how happy he is look how happy I
would kick off those boots and just be
like God listen after you spend after
you spend $100 million on other people's
money and you don't owe a penny back
you're smile too I'm so happy you said
that too if you think about this we all
knew everybody in this room but besides
that that that Witch Hunt that they're
doing
Trump was going to be the front runner
this polls everything this guy spent
over 160 million how much hases Nikki
spent
100 how much Q4 she raised 24 I don't
know how much I heard 60 something to
100 that's 200 and $50 million of M you
already knew you weren't going to win I
think they could have spent that money a
lot better to do a lot better for the
state your state homelessness veterans
that's money down the drain there's no
way you thought you were going to beat
this guy well if you're if you're
shocked now wait till the actual general
election when they start spending
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
Millions for potential losing campaign
what you going to say time you don't
think that that's no because that's not
that's not the way politics work you
round up your donors and you take a shot
heavy is a head that wears a crown you
take a shot you if you got together in
the beginning what would rational let's
just say rational thinkers that are
purely logic said to Barack Obama you're
running against wait a minute you're
running against Hill Hillary Clinton Are
you seriously going to do this are you
going to waste my money no that's not
the way it works they come together and
said I believe I have a chance I believe
I can take a message to the people I'm
going to go do it how much how much you
think is them coming to the candidate
versus a candidate going saying I
believe I have a chance soon as a
candidate raises his hand you have all
those advisers we've had people in this
room that know that system very well and
they say there's a lot of high-end
million-dollar advisors and strategists
that come in because there is an
industry there where people make their
bones and make a living doing this and I
also think that the RNC is and the DNC
have short lfts and people want to come
forward and they want to run the primary
I think it's a little of both you know I
think there there's emissaries hey um
what would you think about uh running
for Senate after your governorship we're
going to have an open seat here there's
a lot of strategy that's on that a huge
amount of strategy is on the seat base
because of the votes in the Senate and
in the um in the in the people's house
the house Representatives a huge amount
of strategy this ISS Pat you you're
you're coming up at the end of your your
Governor's run here um you're going to
have turn limits here in Oklahoma look
we have an open senate seat we need a
strong player in that what do you say
and that happens every day but on the
for the presidency you know a lot of
times people raise their hands and
crowds of folks come to help them do
that and and come to
them what you think you Chris so you
know I remember it was like a couple
years ago um there was like a lot of
momentum for dentists and you probably
all felt it you you heard it and you
know particularly you would see it on
you would see it on Twitter on X you
would really feel like you know there
was there was this me momentum but like
owning Rumble and seeing all the
creators on
Rumble there was the one thing that was
like super consistent on Rumble all the
way through for you know from 2020 till
now is that there was
just an immense amount of momentum for
Trump and it never ever stopped never um
you'd go to Twitter and you'd kind of
see a different perspective but on
Rumble and I I think this is kind of one
of the things people underappreciate
about Rumble is the influence that it
has with the creators that are on there
that never changed now like obviously
there's a lot of creators on Rumble that
were for the santis there's a lot of
creators that refer Trump on Rumble it
was very diverse crowd but the numbers
the large numbers were watching the
Trump stuff and it never wavered it it's
some it's something that I found very
unique I remember telling people that
there's you know I I I don't think based
on what I can see on Rumble there's the
there's nothing slowing down on the
Trump side ever um and I think that was
like a very unique perspective because
if you go on if you go on X you would
have saw something else if you read the
newspapers you would see something else
but uh there there was a movement there
that's that's never gone away not even
close can I ask you a quick question on
that you see numbers there's a lot of
people that are out there that said the
moment that the indictments came down
that there was a spike for Trump because
there was a core of the Republican voter
block that was incensed I'm sure you've
heard those stories too did you see it
in the viewership stats okay so you're
obviously going to get viewership on
events but like you know truth truth
social uses Rumble Cloud as well they
use our our Rumble ads um as well and
you know the users never left they
whether you'd see a spike because of an
event it it didn't it didn't move the
dial on the overall scheme of things
like they they never they never left and
they're they've always been there since
since day
one I mean look let's let's talk let's
talk the VP side Okay so yesterday while
we're doing a conversation you know guys
were asking who do you think could be
the VP and the conversation came about
VI versus uh uh what do you call it
Tulsi Gabbert and uh uh you know who
would be the better match and who would
be a better opportunity for this Etc I
thought Tulsi
would you know I gave my thoughts on
Tulsi versus VI and then all of a sudden
Sebastian Gorka jumps on and says you
know the the vice president's already
been chosen and we already know who it
is it's not who you guys saying it's not
going to be Tulsa and he didn't have
nice things to say about Tulsi and you
know the Trump announced that it's not
going to be Viv as VP there's a story in
here Viv out of Trump's vp's short list
right Viv riswan out of Trump's short
list meaning it could be on the short
list meaning he is on the list forgive
me I didn't say he's not on it so um but
then Sebastian said it's somebody that's
been campaigning this person's from New
York Tom you remember the list this
person's from New York they're a
politician Great American a patriot um
ex a a ex politician for the moment yeah
right and um a great New Yorker right
great New Yorker at and Sebastian Gorka
went down a list this is not
interpreting this is what he was saying
emphatically and this guy says well you
know what about someone like Tulsi I
said he and he was very clear about that
he was very clear about that a magga
supporter and then I
posted uh immediately afterwards seeing
Lee zeldon if you want to go Twitter Rob
Lee zeldon campaigning with Trump I
posted that video and I said could Lee
zeldon be Trump's VP Choice from New
York soy been campaigning formidable
very smart and guess who retweets it
Sebastian Gorka retweets it huh right
after the Twitter space with you know
over half a million people that were on
the Twitter space that listened the
entire time we were on if you go a
little lower look who comments right at
the top the answer no
Roger
Roger so you know when you look at this
there's a couple things that comes to my
mind here's what it
is who has more influence on the inside
who is closer to the president is it
Sebastian is it Roger is it somebody
else or is it misdirection for everybody
in the world for instance when I would
announce a speaker for the event I would
never tell anybody on the inside who the
speaker was because most people cannot
keep a speaker speaker to an event yeah
so one time I'm like guys this next
person we're going to announce to this
event you guys are going to lose it it's
going to be amazing this place is going
to go nuts when you guys here and that
and one guy says Pat I think I know who
it is because I know who would lose it
you had James Worthy you had magic I
think it's Kobe so at this point I'm
like I'm like listen Kobe you know
obviously this is the late Kobe Bryant I
said Kobe would never do an event okay
and if Kobe did you know his schedule
how busy is this how many different
places he has to be so that's a
misdirection for the audience to be like
oh it's for sure not Kobe and then you
you automatically put yeah that person
out of the list and then three months
later you say and our keynote speaker is
Kobe Bryant right so could it be the
fact that everybody is trying to miss I
love the look on your face right now if
we played poker it was a very
interesting look could it be the fact
that there's a lot of you know some
people know but they have to act like
they don't know some people don't know
but they have to act like they know to
be part of the cool crowd no one knows
who knows and who doesn't know and no
one knows who's trying to get cool
points and no one knows Who's acting
dumb yeah so how do you decipher between
all this BS and the reality of it it's
just you have to you know play the odds
and see if you're playing poker does a
guy have you know 210 does he have a
pocket aces does he you know running for
flush what is he doing no one knows but
what do you think about the chances of
Lee zeldon as a VP candidate for Trump
well I don't know Lee that well and uh
you know this isn't my forte of uh of of
you're on all of these guys Chris the
all these guys know who you are I mean
it's you're you we we have a top 50 list
of Power Players we made this year not
only were you on that list but also
Rumble was on that list and Dan Bonino
was on that list I believe so someone we
we put three of you on I think it's two
or three of you guys that was on that
list do you think there's any chance of
zeldon being being the
VP I think there could be a chance I I
think that uh I'm not sure who it is and
um you know I think there's a lot of
good people out there that could be that
pick but uh anybody you like who do you
like who do I like you know I've I've
been asked that question a few times
it's like it's that's a tough one like I
I I don't know like you got to really
know the person to to want to get behind
someone I I don't really know like I for
example I don't know Le Elden I I don't
I don't know a lot of these a lot of
these people so um like you think Dave
Rubin would make a good VP like is that
something because you know Dave right
would you say Dave would you say Viva
fry would you say you know who else
would it be people that you know I don't
think I'm good a good person to to make
that choice or to even you know have a
good opinion on it it's a heck I'm a
Canadian I can't even vote in the
election so yeah but you can you can you
can uh uh you can give thoughts that you
may have Tom what what do you think
about Lee zeldon do you think do you
okay maybe let me ask the question in
this way okay and and this one's going
to be interesting question to ask so
let's not start a fight but it's
probably going to start a fight okay you
have multiple choice okay to answer the
question it's a quiz you're take it's
not a big deal but it's a multiple
choice Adam I want you to think about
this one as well who what are the
chances of who the VP will be okay um
Sebastian Gorka knows better on who the
VP is Roger Stone knows on who the VP is
they're both on the same team and
they're trying to confuse everybody and
last but not least nobody knows multiple
choice A B C or D Gorka Stone both of
them know no one
knows last
one no one knows you said which one no
one knows last I'm on I I agree with d
right now so where are you at I'm on D
um it's really tough because we we know
Roger and we know Goram he just gave a
very good speech at Oxford by the way
speech yeah so who do do which one do
you think it is a C or D Gorka Stone
they both know nobody
knows don't don't let Chris and Adam
change your uh no I I think they both
know and they're not saying anything
about it and by the way they're both
BigTime political operatives so if there
was going to be a misdirection and they
were going to disagree with each other
publicly I think I think that would be a
pretty good misdirection but I'll tell
you I
think Sebastian gorer would be really
going out over his skis if he's going
out in public and laying out those I
mean he basically said Lee Elden without
saying Lee Elden he gave so many
specific facts was he told was he told
to say that because we talked about this
how many times to get the female vote
that we're talking about in all those
places it only makes sense if he goes
for just an average white guy the left
is which who gives a at this point
but they're going to lose their white
guy so you're saying Mike Pen's an above
average black guy yeah well the fly in
his head was black well if we're GNA be
hon we're assuming that it's Lee zeldon
it could be Rudy Giuliani guys you said
a former great New Yorker he made it
clear it's not juli anyway I don't think
and by the way he also said it's not
stefanic cuz somebody else he said a guy
a man but he also said a former she's
current she's a congresswoman but if you
look at traditional politics it makes
zero sense to to take a guy out of New
York the reason that he ran with Pence
was to get the white Christian
Evangelical vote out of Indiana in the
midwest because that was a state that
was ear that that environment is looking
to win he already New York is voting
blue regardless getting someone like Lee
zeldon on the ticket that has zero name
recognition other than the people of New
York makes actually virtually no sense
it's not going to basically you know get
the bay fired up if Trump could run he
would run with Trump and Trump as the VP
if he has a name like that's how like we
putting his his names on on buildings on
casinos just Trump trump 2024 we all
know that but I think the bigger picture
here is who ever he chooses is going to
have an automatic path to the White
House for the next eight years so when I
talk about when we talk about like he
talks about loyal I need loyalty R the
sanct demonus not loyal he's gonna have
to have someone that is undoubtedly
loyal to the Trump brand and that it's
not going to pull uh on the last day of
the uh 2028 Mike Pence and be like ah
well I was just kidding I'm actually not
on team Trump so I think he's got a very
tough decision you going with this do
you have a NE Elden I don't think that
it makes any sense for it to le le Eldon
I think that vivak ramaswami is who the
people want give them what they want or
also think you get a pretty person like
Christy Nome in the mix that could give
her that can give some I heard some I
heard there's no way Christy nome's
gonna I was a Trump International not to
to my own horn Tom but to to you spoke
with the Bellman at Trump International
I spoke I spoke
with I know no not at all guys there are
some Secrets but I I mean I to a lot of
people
there I don't know I I wouldn't I would
I don't see it being Le zent but I do
think that Sebastian and Mar do a little
loopy loop Real Talk have you ever heard
of Lee zelden's name before this I've
seen his face in Congress but never but
he look way too giddy well he ran for
governor against against against Kathy
hul he did all right in New York right
but he's the guy that lost right so I
see okay so since since our friend Chris
here is not going to say anything about
politics let's just do other topics
let's do something because it's either
yes or no I don't know answer I answered
that D I said D
I'm I let's go to the next one here we
go with a big sigh a a paper viiew Super
Bowl it may happen sooner than you think
former ESPN President John Skipper
suggested the idea of making the Super
Bowl a Pay-Per-View event stating if
half the households are willing to pay
$20 to have a party at their house it
will still get you into the billions of
dollars for a single
game the NFL's experiment with pay to
watch playoff football on peacock
resulted in over 23 million viewers
becoming the most viewed watch live
streaming event in US history and
accounting for 30% of internet traffic
that night that is insane wow charging
$99 per pay-per-view per viewer for the
Super Bowl could potentially generate $6
billion in revenue for the NFL which is
comparable to or even exceeds the annual
revenue of other major sports like NHL
and Major League Baseball okay
Tom do you think there's an argument
here that the NFL may be doing a Super
Bowl pay-per-view in the next three to
five years uh not three years because I
think the contracts are out there
however I think Skipper Skipper knows
what he's talking about um I've not met
John I knew other people at ESPN because
I built NFL Mobile back in uh 2007 8 and
N um and I would say in the next five
years is there a chance that in five
years it could be pay-per-view I think
that's very possible we've talked at
length what's happening to Cable
viewership we talked what's happening to
traditional TV we see what's happening
with events that are going on
alternative platforms we see that
peacock put a single NFL playoff game
out there basically causing it to be
pay-per-view because everybody bought
peacock for a day I did and then
canceled it yes I did and and so now I'm
on their list so I think that those kind
of things or tests that became a test
for NBC hey you know what we put one NFL
game out here we got 10 bucks for how
many people for a divisional wild for a
wild card game I think in the next what
happen in five years no will we see an
announcement within 5 years of that
happening I think
absolutely do you think going to happen
do you think do you think it's going to
happen so is the the number I saw was 23
million watched right the question the
the the number one question here is how
many signed up for that event how many
you mean how many stayed on well first
how many new customers did they get you
see if that says it is that is that out
there I don't know if they have reported
that because that's going to inherit all
the previous customers they already had
and the question is how many people with
their Cable packages already had access
to Peacock um to begin with so in order
to L like look at it I think okay so
check this out the game averaged 23
million viewers according to neelon not
bad for a streaming service with only 30
million subscribers so so they only have
30 million so what's their net new so
their net new let's say maybe half that
possibly that's still a big number oh no
it's it's it's a very big number and
they're paying what I think it can go up
to 10 110 million they said oh yeah yeah
can we go all the way up to to let's
look at PE peacock uh membership price
what is peacock's membership price I
think they have a couple tiers one with
ads and one without ads and how
brilliant is it too Chris that that's
it's the Chiefs it's Taylor Swift it's
what's his name and those fans were
definitely downloading or getting it
just to watch her on the field yeah
you're you're going to get a whole new
customer base because of this so it it
it's an a very interesting test but
here's what's going on the war for live
sports has begun NFL on YouTube like
what did they what did they commit 122
billion over a certain amount of years
um even Rumble for example we went and
bid on SLAP we went and bid and got
Nitro rally cross and Street League
Skateboarding the war for live sports is
is finally here and it's now you know
it's becoming it's becoming a war
against uh cable television all these
streaming
platforms don't be surprised to see
Netflix jumping into this would you pay
110 million for an NFL game on Rumble
would that be a worthy number for you we
would have to metric it out and these
this is how we would do it just the way
we're looking is like how many net new
can you get and and what does that look
like if it if they got 23 million new
subs and they're paying an average of uh
$10 200 that would the case yeah that's
that's worth it or you maybe if you do
23 million let's just say they got 25%
new five let's say six million you're
paying six bucks on average that's 36
million but if they if half of them stay
on for six months I mean that you're
you're risking a little bit but long
term it has to be either a minimum Break
Even or you know a number of users that
don't cancel and they keep it well let's
let's put Crowder in in perspective step
Crowder's on Rumble um and he drove $7.5
million in subscription Revenue in his
first five months that's publicly
available that's just one show what he
does is he does an hour live on Rumble
and then he takes the the final half
hour live on locals um the NFL can drive
certainly way more numbers than that and
and I think it's very possible like with
this model the thing is that when you
have too many people buying too many
different things it becomes so
fragmented you really it gets it gets a
lot more difficult but uh for the NFL
that that's a real that's a real draw
that's a real pull you know what's
interesting is the NFL ex me YouTube
didn't just buy the NFL they bought what
was left to Sunday Ticket and now it's
Sunday Ticket on on YouTube TV and you
have to remember what what happened
Sunday Ticket Rob run a PO I don't want
to Rob run a pole would you pay $99 to
watch Super Bowl on pay-per-view I
already did how what's the number right
now right now 93% said no I I don't know
if I believe it I I don't know but by
the way you know out of the 93% the
question would be how many of you guys
would go to a friend's house who did
order it I mean that's the go ahead
illegally so the the case study that
people look to is how Direct TV was made
by NFL Sunday Ticket that was the only
place you could get it $269 a year I
remember this by heart and you got
everything and then the NFL did its own
channel and then the NFL did Thursday
night and then the NFL did Sunday night
on uh National broadcast NBC and and and
and and what happened is there was a
dilutive effect on Sunday Ticket and at
the same time there was a cable and
satellite rollof because infrastructure
providers and so Direct TV started
sagging and said I sorry I'm out I can't
I can't renew this and now you're seeing
the fragmentation of it and the MLB did
it last year they pulled you you're
paying for MLB I pay for the full MLB TV
package and all of a sudden there's
games that have been pulled out Premier
matchups during the week that are now on
Sunday Night on on um ESPN or in a
regional where you couldn't get it and
you're like wait a minute what just
happened here and
so Chris is right the war has just
started and guess what the players in
the war do not care that well people
probably will be upset cuz they already
are buying three or four Services no
they don't care that's not their concern
their concern is monetizing the live
sports event life Sports has advertising
that pencils out because you don't you
don't we used to say you know too or DVR
but you don't fast forward through ads
on live sports you're watching live
sports you watch the ads so the
advertising take and the advertising
yield on live sports is is is is
perfect and so I I and they don't
they're they're they're interested in
monetizing and I think you're you're
going to see it and I think you're
already starting to see little Islands
in the Stream form as that uh what do
they say finding little rocks in the
Stream that they're going to be stepping
on to walk all the way across the river
well I agree with Chris I think the war
for live sports is completely on and
then at the Forefront of the entire war
is the NFL I think at this point we
we're completely comfortable with
calling the NFL complete greedy
corporate capitalists and I don't I
don't mean that as a mad way in a bad
way I think they're just trying to make
that money we saw them increase the NFL
season from 16 games to 17 games G 17
games a season how much money does that
make more for for the league we're
starting to see these games pop up on
Amazon or on peacock like they're going
to go after the money and they'll
probably make a move towards this Super
Bowl thing or whatever they don't mind
getting convincing people to start
spending more money what I do think that
they should be very weary of is getting
back into the social justice movement
which look which worked very uh not well
for them during the Colin kaer Colin
Kaepernick days so what we're starting
to see now is you see at all the NFL
games is racism cool all right I agree
but now you're here for the Super Bowl
this upcoming year which is in what two
three weeks away uh now they're going to
have the black National Anthem sung
before the national anthem so that's
that just starts a whole slippery slope
like don't abandon your base which are
just Americans you know because the the
the natural argument would be all right
so you got the black national anthem
then you know what you're going to have
the Mexican national anthem after that
then you're going to have the Muslim
National Anem it's just like there
should be one Anthem in the United
States and I think that when you know
the the Whitney Houston Whitney Houston
moment 1991 best Super Bowl song best
Super Bowl she sang the
f166 like one national anthem she sang
The Star Spangled Banner it was the most
intense people are crying we're at war
in the desert storm like that's what
America is so to see the NFL we all know
that they're going to go take the money
it's all good but to go the woke route
and have to do that the the black
national anthem just one national an why
do you have a problem with that why do
you have a problem with them playing
black cuz some people may say what's
wrong with them playing a black national
anthem before the national this has
nothing to do with black yellow green
purple anything it has to do with
America I don't know what the black
national anthem is I don't want to know
what it is I don't want to know what the
Catholic national anthem is I don't know
what the Asian national anthem is I
don't need the Jewish I don't need the
Muslim nothing I need one Anthem it's
the anthem of our country American
national anthem Star Spangled Banner
period end of story stop with all the
the kneeling and all that kind of stuff
nobody wants it I I agree in the fact
that I mean he's right it's like what
what one more thing to make people
separated make people talk crap when you
write something like end racism do you
understand how much of an unachievable
goal that that's such a stupid end racis
that's impossible you can't go like go
to Mississippi and you think you're not
going to like cure it's like cure racism
you're not going to do it it's making
people you know what it should say it
should say stop talking about racism
that's leave it like let's just move on
bro if you keep shoving it in people's
faces that's going to piss people off
and make them more Angry you know like
what's the argument for not playing the
black national anthem Adam gave his do
you have a different one no it's it's I
have nothing different it's a country
this is our country the country has a
national anthem thank you very much
there are no other countries that are
represented here today we all come from
somewhere and we become American
citizens in the American experiment the
national anthem is of the country that's
what we're singing here today thank you
very
much it's in Canada did they do anything
other than the Canadian national anthem
did they do like the um so the first the
first people will do hcky will do both
at certain yeah it Us in Canadian and
typically in hockey games no I'm not
talking about singing like sometimes in
in basketball or in Canada in hockey
they'll play the Canadian national
anthem but it's one song right it's a
Canadian National Anthem then we'll do
the United States national anthem but in
Canada do they ever play Trudeau when as
far as taking the word I think sun or
something out of the national them um
put people or them yeah they are I don't
know it's so crazy but like you know you
live in you live in the country of the
sport um you play that you play that
country's Anthem uh I I'm a huge
advocate of just like you know we're
building a video platform this is a
video business nothing else should get
involved in that if you want to do
something that you want to advocate for
go do it on your personal time and
there's nothing wrong with that all
right so this this uh transitions me
into the I'm not transitioning F not
story Nikki Haley claims she was a
victim of racism uh teased every day for
being Brown I that's got to be tough so
let's kind of go through this uh where
did the brown go she's white no she
looks really white Vinnie you got to
respect the story just please like a
little bit compassionate for people's
challenges in their life so let me read
this hang tight for me all right here we
go Republican presidential candidate
Nikki clim she was a victim of racism in
her early childhood during her recent
interview Haley was born in the US to
two seek parents from India thus Haley
claimed while speaking with NBC Sunday
caused her to have a difficult
upbringing while growing up in South
Carolina we were only Indian we were the
only Indian family in our small southern
town the Republican said I was teas
every day for being
Brown so anyone that wants to question
it can go back and look at what I've
said on how hard it is to grow up in the
Deep South as a brown girl during the
interview Haley also noted her hesitancy
to name slavery as a cause of the Civil
War while on the campaign Trail the
response she said was due to her belief
in such information automatic if I
didn't mention slavery on that day is
because that's an automatic she said the
Civil War has always been known about
slavery so watch this Nikki this this is
why I have a problem with your approach
and why so many people we talk to in the
street regular people not a leaders like
you I'm just talking regular people uh
who will look at you and and the way
you're packaging your your your
candidacy versus Viv okay Viv never uses
color as a feel sorry for me never you
use it to get sympathy okay VI um the
the people who are voting for he's also
Indian okay he's not sitting there
saying I was teased for being Brown okay
there is no feeling you get from VI for
being a victim I post a video the other
day and by the way we did this video
while I was in Palm Beach if I look if I
show I want you to see this here Adam
because most people think I made this
video because of EV it just kind of
timed perfectly I'm going to show you
when I posted this video uh Adam and I
want you to tell me the date okay when
is the date for this video okay boom
boom boom boom boom here's the what's
the date January what it says January
15th at 4:57 p.m. can you pull out when
Babylon be story came up about vivean
7-Eleven okay and it it's just just so
accidental that the timing of it was
perfect what's the date is it that one
go to Babylon B website okay what's the
date on that 16 16th that's the next day
the next day so they were inspired by
you I mean me I so I get this video and
I put it on Twitter not thinking anybody
anything about it but watch what vivec
does go to vivec's Twitter account vivec
says thank you for coming and don't
forget to grab a slurpie he's got a s
one side if I would have done this with
Nikki Haley she says this is why racism
exists racism what does Vive says please
grab a slurpie on the way out Nikki
America loves VI for this reason and
America's sick of the that
you're doing to say here feel sorry for
me because I was brown as a kid cry me a
flipping River for taking that approach
America's fed up with these types of
comments okay you made it to the top
instead the message could be look you
know everybody has their own set of
challenges of coming to the top we all
have ours you have you've had yours but
look I what racism Look at me now we've
had a black president we've had all
these people that are winning at the
highest level why are we making this a
big deal today rather you use it as a
method of trying to divide and need some
sympathy votes for people to feel sorry
for again it's not attractive from a
leader standpoint it's not attractive
and by the way somebody said something
yesterday was so interesting they said
Tulsi gabard is everything Nikki Haley
wished she could have been wow okay okay
wished she could have been and she's not
versus Nikki Haley is closer to a
Hillary Clinton than aalsa Gabbert no
doubt people want somebody that's real
that's talking to you she does not give
me that the more she talks the more
feeling I get that her and Hillary are
related 100 and by the way can you go
back to that video just how you know my
grandmother once told me before she
passed away never trust anybody that has
leather shoulder pads look at what the
hell whoever picked that grandma told my
grandmother said never trust that's Wise
by the way P do look at with the collar
never question Assyrian wisdom there's
thank you there it is right there but by
the way you got to give credit to V
Swami because he never never uses the
raise cards he never uses it an excuse
his his whole argument is against
wokeness and and Dei and ESG so it's
antithetical uh to what he stands for
what he you know tweeting about the
slurpie that people thought that he was
going to be upset he leaned into the
joke that's amazing you saw what he did
the other day you know UPS did a big
tweet and he retweeted what could Brown
do for you like Vic don't play when it
comes to jokes and Rays he Jo enjoys it
it's it's just un it's just unattractive
it's just nothing about by the way it's
like the whole jie Smo you want
attention
juy yeah my bad but it's like she knows
she's drowning so what what's the what
card do you play racist feel uh feel bad
for me as if that's going to get you
votes she's dead in the water Tom be
honest for you a man that's open-minded
do you sympathize with the level of
racism that she experienced as a child
for being Brown no I and I think
Elizabeth Warren has been completely
exposed for the things that oh wait a
I'm sorry we're talking about somebody
else oh Nikki Haley well Nikki Haley has
once again has played the you know the
Elizabeth war card trying to trying to
use trying to use color race or or
Association to create affinity and but
it's Affinity not with not with um you
know achievement and anything to be
proud of it's Affinity with victimhood
and I think the whole victimhood thing
is disgusting to people I think that's
what makes Vic you know attract
attractive to people in his message he
say sir you know what he's not EV viive
he's just getting up there and he's
doing his thing speaking it and he is
who he is who do you think's decision
that was to do the cuz I mean she has a
team right is that is that her decision
to bring that up or somebody goes you
know what go for the brown racist
strategist and handlers that are telling
her don't bring up slate that's what
they didn't want her to say I'm going to
tell you this go I'm going to tell you
this it's 100% her decision what do you
what do you talking about it's your
decision everybody can give me feedback
whatever they want to give me I made the
decision I'm a shot caller you're a shot
caller that's your decision we can
easily and by the way even when you say
like you know when I give the story
about Romney on the flight with Bill
O'Reilly I'm going to Vegas somehow some
of were sitting right next to each other
I'm like hey what happened why did
Romney lose I thought he was going to
win and it says he listened to his
campaign strategies that said don't be
mean on the last one because you beat
him up so hard Obama with Benghazi on
the last one you're losing single female
voters so talk about salads I'm not not
saying salad you understand what I'm
saying so okay you're in a room your
your campaign strategist comes up to you
says Vinnie on this next campaign wear
shorts and a tank top show your tattoos
in the debate M because if you do you're
going to get the single female vote and
Middle America is going to like you how
short of this short now if you you do it
if you sit there and you say what a
freaking great idea you deserve
everything you get okay everything you
get you going to be very famous to show
up there on stage and do your thing but
you know that's the part where you got
to make a decision and say look this is
my brand you know what my brand is black
shirt nice little cross that I just
bought sick with my manck money I got
nice watch I'm weing my nice and I'm
coming out you put in your pants just to
kind of look aier why do people love you
cuz you're Vincent oano you're authentic
that's true the more PE I'm being very
sincere with you you're loved the way
you are because you're straight up and
you're sincere and authentic and some of
these politicians just don't even know
how to do that it's let me go give a
speech here to to one these guys or I'll
flip it can come and give the speech
here to Wi these guys I'll go over there
and give this guys you know say what you
want about the santis whether you like
him or don't like him politically he is
who he is I I you know I asked him a
question about his boots I was hoping he
would do something so people would laugh
and he would laugh at himself kind of
like a self-deprecation moment guess
what he doesn't know how to do that he
just doesn't have that Vic has it Trump
has it you know Clinton has it some
people have it he even George Bush has
it remember he went on and you know oops
or you know all these other things I'm
not talking Governor Perry but even
George Bush he know how to laugh at
himself it's a very interesting thing to
have America likes that he doesn't know
how to do that but at least he stayed
very consistent he shared his values and
America said no man you're not number
one maybe you'll have a different job
but Haley is a well I think part of the
reason that you're upset by this well
probably a lot of Republicans are upset
by this is because typically identity
politics and race politics is owned and
operated by the left and the Democrats
what are you doing so um you know that's
how we have a vice president named
Harris because they didn't they weren't
looking on meritocracy they weren't
looking on policy they weren't even
looking on personality quite frankly
they were looking to check a box for the
VP and boom you know what would make
sense though you know what would make
sense though here's what would make
sense
okay Tom uh um Chris odds of this odds
of this
okay do do you know how when's the last
time a candidate from the right left the
party who's the last person that left
the party what do you mean the candidate
on the right somebody from the right
that left the party you know RF they
just left a left a left and went and
became a what he became she be he became
an independent right Tulsa Tulsi left
the left and she went and became an
independent right but when the last time
somebody on the right left not to go to
the left some sometimes go to the center
yeah Republicans leave to go to
Independent status right right guess
what Nikki Haley maybe that's a good
strategy for you exactly go go be that
go be a you know Center left person and
use your skin color racism and female
and women and all this stuff maybe that
audience will like you and by the way in
New Hampshire you know how many
Democrats they were talking about
wanting to vote just so Trump loses in
New Hampshire she's getting Democratic
votes maybe she'll get some votes on the
other side so what if she left the party
and went and became a Democrat or Center
left that would be interesting Joe Li
well this goes to my this goes to my
initial point where I think in 2024 this
might help her a little bit but when she
loses to Trump this is going to backfire
tremendously in 2028 so she's going to
get a little bump in New Hampshire she
might compete in South Carolina not
really but when all is said and done in
30 days when she drops out of the race
MaGa on the right wing won't will not
forget who she is her career will
officially be finished but Ronda santis
because he ran to the right of trump
will still have a chance in 2028 wow
Nikki just says I'm a I'm a Democrat now
and then she runs with m is I think
she's a corporate bureaucrat I don't
think she's a Democrat I think she's
taking the money she's playing the
identity Politics the game by way okay
right there she's taking the money of
course she is so watch this why does he
like Dave port no's deal why is Chris
happy about Dave port no's deal he took
Equity because when somebody takes
Equity what do they saying I really
believe in longterm on what's going to
happen but there are some people right
now that are calling me and I'm talking
to them and they're saying hey man I
want to sell my podcast for this this
this and that I said you want me to get
you a buyer I'll I'll introduce you to
Chris I'll introduce you to this guy
talk to them see what they want okay if
you're looking for a check these people
get a lot of eyeballs right there are
guys in the political side that just
want a check there are guys that want a
partnership there are guys that want
Equity Dave wants a partnership that's
what Dave's got with the announcement
that you made today right but I think
Nikki Haley obviously going and sitting
on the boing uh uh uh board that's money
you didn't go to boing because you're
like oh my God I just love the planes
you guys make you guys change people's
lives with these doors opening and the
plane in Miami on fire isn't that great
it's like better than fireworks I love
you guys you guys are awesome can you
play the video of the Miami plane going
just on fire flying the lady is
screaming saying what the hell is going
on so guess what Democrats if Adam says
she's a what did you call her she's a
corporate corporate uh sto or I don't
know what I call her that's by the way
that's the pl and and I want this lady
to say her thing and then I'll give my
sinere shout boing in Miami in Miami
listen to this
lady oh you don't have the lady what she
says cuz she's a what she say dud that's
all my luck that'd be the flight that
I'm on I'm just telling you right now
yeah on
fire oh my God sorry can you imagine
you're on the flight it's on fire and
they have to turn around and come
back by the way there's a reason why
people are afraid of heights because
they were on a flight like this for the
rest of their life they're miserable let
me finish this up so maybe this isn't
even a message to Nikki Haley maybe it's
for Democrats that listen to the podcast
many do maybe this is an opportunity for
you you know what I'm saying like go
this is an opportunity get somebody to
go on the left you know how big of an
announcement that would be for the left
if they announced Nikki Haley who was
the person that almost beat Trump she
finally saw the BS in Trump she is now a
Democrat wow the trade it would be a
brilliant strategy for the to consider I
think big time and then guess what she
and then once m Michelle Obama goes hey
I'm running Run start a podcast on
Rumble do a podc and call it we trade it
the trade but by way you showed that
video trade yeah the Miami I just I
don't know why the first that jumped in
my head atam was a flight attendant
going just Jesus Christ just don't look
up the flight attendant on that airplane
they must have been going crazy the
whole engine was it was a cargo plane so
I don't believe there that's boring Then
There Goes my joke great it's just a
metaphor thanks for ruining everything
that's just a metaphor for the last week
of her campaign that's what whether it's
a whether it's a cargo plane or not it's
a Boeing plane no yeah Rob is that a Bo
plane it was it was a boing is yeah
Boeing 7478 cargo's not doing well and
then the ESG and the doors they're
killing it they just announced after
last week they're like moving forward
we're going to have convertible planes
really with outo swimming pool nice just
go take a bath in the back
oh
[Laughter]
latest uh uh new advancement in boing
they're introducing convertible planes
by the by the time the flight is done
everybody's got slick back hair forget
about Botox you going like this and fr
by anyways folks this is a joke don't go
share the story with others boing is
introducing convertible planes that
wouldn't work in today's economy it
would be a
bad anyways we got a lot of other
stories to cover we'll do one home team
together as well this has been a bless
Chris you the man happy for you congrats
big deal phenomenal story to go from
where you're at to where you are now and
uh you know dropping out and you know
doing what you're doing with websites
and then all of a sudden you build this
thing and turns into 60 million people
visiting the site getting millions of
eyeballs some of the biggest brands
choosing to join you with Rumble very
excited for you the the the part for me
that I'm most excited for rumble I said
this I think I said this a year and a
half ago when when the whole Spotify
thing that happened yep not even a year
and a half ago I said this two years ago
when we sat down at the house we were
talking later at night after we had
dinner at Kasa D'Angelo I said this is
why I trust capitalism and I love
capitalism because when YouTube was
doing what it was doing censoring videos
then what happened a guy like Chris said
look that's not cool we're going to make
it work trust me guys running a business
it is a 100 times harder than you even
know it a lot of people say oh look at
this rich guy got $400 million do you
know how many sleepless nights this
guy's had to probably get the business
to where it's at today that's why I
respect him because it's hard to be an
operator it is harder than you even
think it is it's very very hard to be an
operator never to give up and all these
people creating content because somebody
was stubborn enough to not take all the
push in The Bullying behind closed doors
and he stood he stood calm he believed
in his stuff family was backing him up
and then you build something like this
but I love capitalism I trust capitalism
capitalism makes guys like you come out
and say no that's not cool I have an
idea I think we can do it better like
this capitalism says you know what I'm
worth $300 billion I can date anybody
out there in the world and I probably
have and I got some money it's around
$300 billion not that much but you know
what not as if my life isn't crazy
enough right now I'm going to buy this
company called Twitter and I'm going to
pay $30 billion more than what it's
really worth because I believe freedom
of speech is that much that important
right then Daniel E when when they try
to trash uh what do you call itan he
said no no no no listen I'm over here in
my country don't bother us you Americans
trying to turn everybody into this and
this and that we like what Rogan's doing
we're sticking with them
Rumble you you know Spotify Twitter X
now many of these guys due to capitalism
competing uh force their competitors to
sit there and say maybe we are not
making the best decisions right now
maybe we ought to take a different kind
of a route and I applaud you I respect
you for doing that again Rob if you want
to go back to man for some of you guys
that watch this and you want to give
this man a shout out or ask him a
question how do you go through the tough
times to get to where you are today just
make sure don't ask him political
questions cuz he's going to say yes or
no political questions you can man with
them that's his QR code at the bottom
but definitely do give him a shout out
for him being on the podcast here today
take care everybody tomorrow morning we
are back on I think home team tomorrow
we got 40 stories we haven't gone
through that we will get through
tomorrow morning take care everybody
bye-bye